welcome to the man of recaps this is the
complete recap of all the marvel netflix
shows aka
the defender verse it all began with
daredevil season one meet matt murdock
the blind attorney who by day defends
the innocent with his law degree but by
night he defends the innocent with his
fists yes the talks of chemical spill
that left him blind heightened his other
senses so he can hear well enough to see
much like a bat unfortunately the name
batman was already taken so here we are
he's not called daredevil yet just a man
in black and he runs around hell's
kitchen fighting bad guys with epic
one-take hallway scenes yeah oh god
that's what made the show famous
his best friend and law partner is funny
guy foggy nelson when he gets real cut
up he has a nurse friend claire temple
to sew him back together and he's a good
catholic boy his other best friend is
the confessional but one day karen page
finds herself framed for murder with
matt superhearing he knows she's
innocent so nelson and murdock take
the case so with daredevil's super
karate skills he cuts to the core of
this conspiracy exposes union allied and
the day is saved
except they get off because they're
threatening the jury matt tracks down
the name of the big shadowy crime boss
who's controlling it all
wilson fisk we meet him in romance mode
he just met an art dealer vanessa that
he's head over heels for he's got a real
fun way of talking he's all like
this city is my home and i'll do
anything to protect it he's generally a
cool collected dude but beneath the
surface is an endless pick
of rage epic table flip now
unfortunately fisk has most of the
police in his pocket so matt has to beat
up some cops which earns him the
nickname the devil of hell's kitchen
well matt's out punching people karen
and foggy are working to take down fisk
legally by the way foggy doesn't approve
of matt's nighttime hobbies once he
finds out matt daredevil he becomes very
annoying basically the only thing he
ever says is matt you should stop being
daredevil long story short matt finally
finds a corrupt cop who's willing to
testify so they get the police force
cleaned up and fisk is going to jail
for all of five seconds he immediately
breaks out now there was a subplot this
season with matt's blind old man mentor
stick who trained him as a kid he's
caught up in an ancient ninja war
between good and evil matt's like yo i'm
busy with fisk i don't have time for
ninja stuff come back next season when
that'll be the main plot he does though
fight one ninja nobu who cuts him up
real bad before matt's able to burn him
there's like yo man this underarm ain't
cutting it anymore you need a super suit
and so for the final showdown with fisk
matt shows up in his new daredevil
outfit they have a big old fight fisk is
very strong by the way but in the end
matt lets the devil out boom
fist goes to jail and daredevil
officially gets his superhero name next
up is jessica jones season one
jessica jones is a private investigator
as a kid she was in a car crash where
her whole family died but somehow she
woke up with super strength
and arguably her real super power
superhuman alcohol tolerance now one day
a nice midwestern girl hope
kills her parents in the elevator but it
wasn't her she was being mind controlled
yes jessica has a history with this
villain his name is kilgrave and any
command he gives you you have to follow
he walks around the world turning people
into his personal slaves jessica's full
of trauma from when she was under his
control but luckily one day he was hit
by a bus and she was able to break free
but now he's back in town and creepily
obsessed with jessica the one that got
away so to prove hope's innocence
jessica goes to jaren hogarth master
attorney of questionable morality she's
like yeah the mind control offense could
be interesting if you can find any proof
so jessica tracks down killgrave oh snap
it's doctor who but when he can turn
anyone around him into a bodyguard it's
hard to catch him so just gets help from
her best friend and adopted sister trish
walker she was a child star
it's patsy but is trying to distance
herself from that now and there's
malcolm the junkie who lives next door
likes to sneak in and steal her peanut
butter turns out though he's not just on
drugs he's on mind control but once jess
helps him get clean he's a real smart
guy a valued member of the team by the
way there was a cop who was kill graves
to kill trish but ended up banging trish
to stop killgrave he started taking
super steroid pills but they made him a
bit crazy turn him into a villain to
stop him trish took one of his pills and
together the girls took him down
but trish got her first taste of
superpowers watch out for that later
there's also the hot new bartender
jessica's been flirting with
luke cage turns out he's even stronger
than he looks in fact he's got
superpowers powers he's invincible when
he and just realize they both have
superpowers they get hit on
superhero style sweet christmas turns
out though he's investigating his dead
wife reeva who was hit by a bus but she
was actually with kilgrave and jessica
they were digging up a usb drive she had
and it wasn't the bus that hit her it
was jessica that killed her on
kilgrave's
orders and so after some failed attempts
to catch kill grave kilgrave takes the
whole police station hostage
hello jessica he's like yo i'm not gonna
use my powers on you i love you and want
you to fall in love with me naturally
come out to the suburbs with me and i'll
beauty and the beast you so jessica
plays knights for a bit but she tricked
him and locked him in the cage
and so long story short kilgrave's
parents come but everything turns into a
mess and he's able to escape but when he
commands jessica to let go she doesn't
do it
yes it wasn't the bus that broke her
free of his powers it was when he made
her kill her eva somehow his powers
don't work on jess anymore luke cage
comes in to help but kilgrave makes him
blow up his bar not knowing he's
fireproof he goes full khaleesi so now
he's here to help which is maybe a bad
idea cause kilgrave can't control
jessica but he can control luke it's a
super strength fight in the unjessica
blam shotgun to the face which does
knock him out and who's on duty that
night but nurse claire temple who's like
well i guess i'm a superhero specialist
now so long story short kilgrave and
jack's feet is juiced into his brain
which gives him a superpower up so in
the final showdown he's like jessica
stop
and it works so he can control her now
except just kidding she was faking
boom kills him they didn't need him
alive anymore hope ended up dying anyway
so the day is kind of saved next up is
daredevil season two now daredevil
follows batman rules he doesn't kill
people he only injures them grievously
but there's a new vigilante in town who
does kill bad guys he's a one-man army
and it is the punisher he and daredevil
butt-heads a bit it's like hey red you
don't kill people but i do so get over
it so karen page now accidentally
reporter is investigating the punisher
turns out his name was frank castle he
was a good war hero till his family was
accidentally killed in a big gang
shootout it seems like there's a big
cover up so to get to the bottom of it
nelson and murdock take his case but
wait there's something else going on he
throws the case so he can go to jail
where he meets wilson fisk
yes when fisk first got to prison there
was some other kingpin in charge but
with the punisher he sees an opportunity
he's like yo man that guy was part of
the drug deal where your family got shot
and punisher's like well point me at him
frank takes that guy out but now fisk
controls the prison opens all the other
cages so frank has his own epic hallway
fight scene
fisk is like wow you're really good at
killing i'm going to let you out so you
can take out all my rivals while i'm in
here so turns out the shootout worse
family died was part of a sting
operation set up by the da but she's
trying to cover it up and now oh someone
kills her but it wasn't frank and to
prove it someone else is shooting at him
turns out the big drug dealer involved
was the blacksmith so frank tracks him
down but it actually turns out the real
blacksmith was frank's old marine
commander karen's like yo don't kill him
he can testify but frank's like nah i
just like killing people so the punisher
leaves to go start his own series and
the day is saved until matt gets a visit
from his ex-girlfriend elektra hey baby
hope you brought your super suit because
we're fighting ninjas together their old
blind sensei stick shows up did somebody
say fighting ninjas and he tells them
these evil ninjas they're fighting are
called the hand
and somehow the hand leaders are
immortal the ninja nobu that daredevil
burn in season one he's back he's fine
but he doesn't want to fight elektra he
wants to fight for elektra yes turns out
she's the black sky
the mythical hero of the hand who's like
a super killing monster stick found her
as a kid and tried to turn her into a
good guy but she still just really likes
killing she loves matt though so he
convinces her to use her killing powers
on the hand and there's a lot more ninja
fighting the hand has a literally
infinite supply of ninjas and so now
fighting ninjas together matt and
electra have fallen in love they decide
to go facebook official and in the final
fight with nobu elektra oh sacrifices
herself to save matt
no elektra you can't die and indeed she
doesn't die because her grave is robbed
and she's put into a weird sarcophagus
by the hand
wow next up is luke cage season one so
after his bar blew up luke cage moved to
harlem where he's working at pop's
barbershop he's also bartending at
harlem's paradise the hottest music club
in the neighborhood and also the
headquarters of harlem's crime boss
cornell cottonmouth stokes cornell's
cousin mariah dillard is his legitimate
connection she's a city council woman
and his right-hand man always wears
sunglasses goes by shades so one night
some local kids have the bad idea to
jack some of cottonmouth's money so the
last kid goes to pops to make a deal
he'll give the money back they won't
kill him but one of cottonmouth's men no
respect shoots up
pops oh no pops is neutral it's
switzerland
luke cage is mad he busts into where
cornell keeps his money stash goes full
darth vader from rogue one
takes one bag of money to repair the
barbershop and leaves the rest for the
cops to find including detective misty
knight who is a crime scene savant she
can always tell how things went down
long story short having a bulletproof
guy messing with his affairs drives
cornell to get sloppy one night he and
his cousin mariah are having a fight
which goes back to their childhood
raised by the original crime boss mama
mabel stokes and the uncle pete who
abused mariah when cornell says she
wanted it oh that's crossing the line oh
she pushes him out the window and beats
him to death
shades was there to see that he's like
alright mariah you're the crown boss of
harlem now
unfortunately just then there's a new
player in town who goes by diamondback
takes out all these guys like
no actually i'm the crime boss of harlem
he shoots luke cage with a judas bullet
made from alien metal oh that takes him
down luckily luca just met up with nurse
claire temple who saved his life in
jessica jones she's here to help again
but you can't do surgery on invulnerable
skin so we get luke's backstory his real
name was carl lucas who was a cop that
was wrongfully imprisoned and the prison
psychiatrist there was riva yes luke's
feature love that's where they met but
long story short they were doing illegal
experiments on the prisoners there and
the one on luke actually worked he came
out super strong and indestructible
punched his way out of prison so they
tracked down the scientists that did the
experiments give luke an acid bath to
soften them up so they can get the
bullet out so back in harlem turns out
diamondback
is luke's illegitimate brother and for
some reason that makes him angry in fact
boom he blows up
pops again and comes in wearing the
ugliest super suit in the mcu it does
make him bulletproof though and super
strong so it's a final street fight but
the people of harlem are on luke's side
and boom luke cage wins
and luke cage unfortunately is under
arrest for escaping prison back in
atlanta he and claire had a romance this
season they have a big ol smooch and he
goes off to finish his sentence then
it's time for iron fist season one
meet danny rand from the billionaire
rand corporation but he and his family
supposedly died in a plane crash when he
was a kid
apparently he survived though and he
comes back now 15 years later wearing no
shoes he finally makes it to see the
meecham's the co-owners of the company
this american psycho looking guy is ward
meecham and it's a sister joy he looks
like a crazy bum though so they haven't
committed where he explains he was saved
by interdimensional kung fu monks and
there he received the power of the iron
fist whoa
with the help of family lawyer jerry
hogarth he finally proves his identity
so danny rand is back a 51
owner of the rand corporation he spent
his life studying karate though he knows
nothing about business and this is a
huge problem for ward so ward goes to
get help from his father harold
meacham which is only weird because he
was also supposed to have died 10 years
ago turns out harold mitchum made a deal
with the hand
they saved his life in exchange they
control rand behind the scenes so harold
brings danny in like hey man do you want
to use your kung-fu skills to beat up a
bunch of evil ninjas called the hand but
then he's like yo this is a crazy
coincidence because my full job title is
the immortal iron fist protector of
kunlun
sworn enemy of the hand and he likes to
tell people that a lot he finds the
leader of the hand madame gao who we
actually met in daredevil season one
even wilson fisk was nice to her and
indeed denny tries to stop her but it's
like [ __ ] please i'm madame gao
now earlier danny met colleen wing the
martial arts instructor but danny's like
yo i actually swore a vow of chastity so
he can't do anything sexual but when she
shows him her boobs he immediately
breaks that bow now colleen's actually
been teaching our nurse claire temple
what part of town does she live in
together they fly over to china for some
more kung fu movie tropes then he
realizes the plane crash wasn't an
accident his father was killed by the
hand
and so iron fist boom captures madame
gao they bring her to colleen's kung fu
college and her sensei bakuta bakut is a
real nice dude do they do some tai chi
and drink some chai tea but it seems too
good to be true he's probably secretly
evil and indeed danny talks to madame
gao who reveals bakuta
is part of the hand colleen tries to
explain madam gao is part of the bad
hand and she and bakuda are part of the
good hand
our kung fu clans are sworn enemies but
you and me could be like romeo and
juliet but danny never had eighth grade
english he doesn't know what that is
pretty soon though calling realizes
she's working for the bad guys so she
has her final fight with her sensei
bakuda katana time yeah she wins and
somewhere in there denny's best friend
from konlan davos shows up he's here to
bring danny back see the iron fist's
soul job is to protect the
interdimensional past and right now it's
unguarded but it was so super boring
that's why danny left and he's like yo
man i just i'm going to stay in new york
so for now it seems the day is saved
except the real bad guy is harold
meacham yesterday's out it wasn't madame
gav who caused the plane crash it was
harold meachum to take over the company
in fact ward tried to kill his evil
undead dad but it didn't take whatever
the hand did he keeps coming back so
danny busts in there does a big old iron
fist ground punch then he's going to let
him live but ward meacham's like oh i'm
not taking any chances shoots him
multiple time off the building and
cremates him so the day is saved and
danny's like you know maybe i should go
check on that pass just in case but when
he arrives there's blood everywhere and
kunlun has vanished he's like you know i
think i've made a huge mistake
and now it's time for the big crossover
the defenders
at the end of daredevil season 2 the
hand dug up electra's body and put it in
the creepy blood sarcophagus
and whoa brought her back to life she
was always an excellent fighter but now
she is a fully realized black sky
an avatar of death she's pretty amnesia
though so she's being manipulated by the
hands big top leader sigourney weaver
alexandra they have some master plan
going on in new york and whatever it is
it's causing earthquakes and all four of
our heroes get dragged into it one way
or another danny ran to the immortal
iron fist investigating the hand after
they destroyed kunlun apparently jessica
jones private investigator working a
case when a ninja shows up so matt
murdock shows up to be her lawyer and
his season two he fought the hand so he
knows what's up now luke cage was sent
back to seagate prison at the end of his
season but now with the help of super
lawyer foggy nelson they clear his name
he's out but now look here some new
ninja gang is recruiting young harlem
kids so he's looking into it he runs
into danny rand doing his thing
finds out that luke cage can't be karate
but what about the iron fist unstoppable
force immovable object
bam pretty soon they realize they have
claire as a mutual friend so they swap
backstories danny apparently fought an
actual dragon anyway he tries to fight
the hand using his billionaire business
powers but their whole board is ninjas
so it's karate time again just then matt
and jessica's investigation leads them
here too and so all four defenders are
united
for an epic hallway fight yeah
yes the defenders have assembled except
assembled is the avengers thing the
defenders just kind of meet up they take
their meat up to a chinese restaurant
where stick shows up and fills them in
on the whole ancient war with the evil
shadow ninjas standard stuff of course
for danny and matt but luke and jessica
is a little out of their wheelhouse
earlier matt saw elektra and was
obviously very surprised to see her
alive but she didn't remember him so now
they fight some more ninjas and matt
takes a lecture outside like hey baby i
love you don't be evil but she's still a
lemni jed they managed to capture one of
the leaders of the hand though he's one
of the five
fingers of the hand and remember they're
all used to being immortal they have a
substance that is the blood sarcophagus
stuff that revived electra unfortunately
that was the last of it they're mortal
now they're trying to get more and
somehow to do that they need the iron
fist since the iron fist is the key to
their plan they want to hide to danny
but danny doesn't want to be sidelined
so they have a little fight wow
in the end they tie him up to keep him
safe but stick is like hey sorry about
this kid but to keep you even safer i'm
gonna kill ya just then no elektra shows
up for her final showdown with her old
sensei stick and oh
she kills him she takes danny back to
the hand but now oh she kills alexandra
she's like yo i'm sick of taking orders
i'm the leader of the hand now so
elektra takes danny to the mystic seal
door like hey punch through this for me
he's like no i'm gonna punch you instead
but
she grabs his fist puts it in there and
he's like oh i've maybe made a huge
mistake and turns out what's down here
is
a literal dragon skeleton yes it's
dragon bones that make up the substance
that keeps them immoral but the bigger
problem is when they remove the skeleton
it's going to unleash an earthquake that
will destroy all of new york so the
defenders suit up for the final showdown
daredevil with an actual super suit kind
of the odd man out they go down to the
cave and they have an epic final ninja
fight yeah
upstairs colleen and clara going to
demolish the building colleen has a
rematch with bakuta but just then
detective misty knight shows up to help
and ho katana cuts her arm off
she did not see that coming then matt
sends the other defenders away for his
final showdown with elektra they fight
it out super karate time but in the end
it's like baby don't be evil i love you
but she's like oh but i like being evil
so these two start making out as the
bombs go off drop in the building on top
of them
and they die in each other's arms so the
day is saved except misty knight lost
her arm and of course matt's dead but
turns out
matt survived yes he's picked up by nuns
apparently and that's how the defenders
comes to an end
but we are only halfway done because now
it's the punisher season one
in daredevil season two frank castle
killed everyone involved in the big
shootout that killed his family so his
quest for vengeance is over
but soon he's contacted by master
computer guy micro and turns out the
conspiracy goes even deeper than we
thought
micro was an nsa analyst who tried to
whistleblow the illegal stuff that
frank's black ops unit was doing in
afghanistan yes frank thought he was
over there fighting terrorists but turns
out they were taking out friendly
targets to line their pockets with
heroin for the blacksmith so frank
tracks this guy down and learns the true
secret of the nicest family died it was
all set up
by these black ops guys to silence frank
because he knew too much
and it was all orchestrated by shady cia
guy agent orange now agent madani is
investigating the same situation and she
tracks down frank's old best friend
billy russo he thought frank was dead
though so she doesn't get any
information from him but they do
get it on but now billy finds frank best
friends for united but turns out billy
is working for
agent orange betrayal pretty soon though
frank realizes his friend billy's
portrayed him and he asked to fake take
hostage his friend karen page these two
kind of have some chemistry are they
gonna hook up well they don't for now
frank does accidentally hook up with
micro's wife because she thought he was
dead it's a whole thing but they take my
gross family hostage so they have to do
a deal micro trades himself but oh he
gets shot frank pulls back out his
punisher body armor and goes on an epic
rampage using a variety of different
guns belongs to a short he gets captured
so agent orange can finally finish him
off but turns out micro faked his death
and frank let himself get captured yeah
now they're gonna get it all on tape so
once he tricks him into confessing frank
breaks free and kills agent orange billy
russo like okay no hard feelings frank
i'm just gonna get out of here but
frank's never gonna let him go because
it was his best friend billy russo who
killed his family
betrayal it comes down to the final
fight on the merry-go-round where frank
doesn't kill billy but he smashes his
face into the mirror getting it all cut
up
and the new head of the cia is like hey
frank sorry one of our rogue agents
killed your family um where are you
gonna cover this all up you go live your
life next up it's jessica jones season
two so life goes on for jessica jones
her neighbor malcolm is now her pi
assistant and her best friend trish
walker is using her celebrity powers to
investigate how jessica got her powers
turns out after the car crash she was
experimented on by a company called igh
but now this other guy who got speedster
powers from igh is murdered someone's
trying to cover it all up jessica tracks
down the super power to enforce her but
turns out it's a middle-aged woman who's
whoa
stronger than jessica they track down
the nurse who leads them to the janitor
who leads them to dr carl who's now
dating the super-powered woman but at dr
carl's house jessica finds a picture of
herself as a kid
yes this woman is jessica's mom she was
horribly burned in the car crash they
had to reconstruct her face from scratch
that's why jessica didn't recognize her
long story short the experiment saved
her life and gave her super strength but
she was never let out into the real
world again because she has
uncontrollable fits of rage
now she's excited to reconnect with her
daughter jessica and this is complicated
for jess but eventually she does the
right thing and turns her into the cops
jessica's lawyer jerry hogarth to help
out but holgarth has her own problems
turns out she's dying of als and long
story short she gets conned by these
people that say they have healing powers
they just steal everything meanwhile
trish got a taste of superpowers last
season with simpson's pills he comes
back briefly he traded his pills for a
super inhaler and turns out
whoa that inhaler is good stuff she runs
around thinking she's a superhero but
really she's just a crazy person beating
people up on the bus and as you might
imagine this inhaler is pretty addictive
and she has a history of drug abuse from
one she was a pop star so it sends her
spiraling out of control and it gets
even worse when she finally runs out she
kidnaps dr carl wants him to give her
superpowers but his technique is not fda
approved it goes wrong jess has to bust
in there and stop it and dr carl
realizes he's done more harm than good
for the world so he blows himself and
his research up this sends jess's mom
into a rage she goes out of control
kills more cops but at times her mom's a
real good person and jessica doesn't
want to lose her she finally agrees to
turn herself back in but just then oh
she's shot
by trish yes trish is like sorry jess
but your mom's a monster someone had to
put her down so the day is kind of saved
except it's horribly traumatic for jess
and these two are no longer friends next
up it's luke cage season two
life is good for luke cage the hero of
harlem things are going great with the
nurse claire but one day beating up bad
guys he almost kills this guy claire's
like we should talk about your anger
issues and to prove he doesn't have any
anger issues he punches all in the wall
so it's like yeah we're breaking up so
luke focuses on work shutting down crime
but crime has never shut down for long
mariah dillard has fully taken up her
cousin's mantle as crime boss of harlem
with her partner shades and these two
are dating by the way so good for them
but there's a new player in town a
jamaican who goes by bushmaster he is an
epic breakdance fighter and more than
that he's bulletproof too
his power comes from the jamaican herb
nightshade and with it even luke cage
can't stop him but bushmaster has some
sort of personal beef with mariah stokes
yes dillard was her married name from
her dead doctor husband she was born
mariah stokes granddaughter of mama
mabel their families used to be partners
but their stokes betrayed the
bushmasters killed his old family so now
he's here for revenge he leaves mariah
to burn and claims harlem as his
birthright luke has to say mariah from
him so she can go to jail but luke just
can't beat this guy and he's got the
pocket sand oh i'm paralyzed oh kicked
in the river luke may be bulletproof he
can definitely drown but luckily it
wears off before he does so luke gets
help from detective misty knight who had
her arm cut off with a katana in the
defenders but billionaire danny rand
hooked her up with a sweet robot arm and
now she kicks more ass than ever
speaking of danny rand he comes in for
one team up episode and it is
legitimately sweet
these two need a heroes for higher
spin-off show but back to mariah she's
done messing around and burns up
bushmaster's whole civilian friends
this is too much even for shades she
broke the rules of the streets she's got
to go down also mariah has an estranged
daughter who's coincidentally the
herbalist that's been supplying
bushmaster with nightshade and when she
sees what her mother did she's like yo
bushmaster i'm fully on your side now
here's a super nightshade shot so he
busts in there to kill mariah and once
again luke's got to stop him to save
mariah to get her to jail this time boom
he finally lands a big hit
knocks bushmaster all the way back to
jamaica and now with the smoking gun
mariah dillard stokes is going to jail
except she's still super rich and
powerful will probably get off so her
daughter goes for the kiss on the lips
which you only do if you're wearing
poison game of thrones lipstick and
mariah dies
but this leaves a power vacuum in harlem
luke cage can't be everywhere at once so
he makes a deal with neighboring crime
bosses look consider harlem my territory
don't be coming in doing any crime there
in fact mariah left harlem paradise to
luke cage in her will
hoping that like being the king would
corrupt him but he doesn't see himself
as the king he sees himself as more of a
sheriff misty knight though like yo luke
um are you a crime boss now but he's
like no no it's more like i'm the boss
of crime
and the last scene is an homage to the
godfather as the doors closed on her
while luke does business and we're left
to wonder will luke lose himself going
down this dark path
next up is iron fist season two danny
rand continues to defend chinatown with
his magic glowy fist he's still dating
colleen wing you know what they say the
couple that fights triads together stays
together but this season his friend
davos is the villain he's mad at danny
for abandoning kunlun which yeah was
totally his bad but more than that he's
jealous because he wants the iron fist
for himself at the big ritual fight they
did to see who would get it danny only
won because he walked him into the sun
cheap move bro by the way joy meacham is
working with davos as a villain this
season for reasons i don't know so one
day danny meets a nice new girl in town
mary walker but there's something about
mary she leaves herself notes and when
there's running water she freaks out yes
she's got a split personality her alter
ego goes by her last name walker and is
a badass bounty hunter she's a top tier
fighter knocks danny out delivers him to
davos who takes some of his blood to do
a tattoo ritual that comes with oh
a red iron fist he believes the iron
fist was meant to be used to root out
evil and kill anyone who's even remotely
bad when he took the fist away he broke
dany's leg leaving danny out of
commission but his girlfriend colleen's
like yo you rest boo i got this she
teams up with her new best friend
detective misty knight and for a while
these two carry the show making the case
for their own daughters of the dragon
spin-off eventually danny's leg is
mostly healed but he talks to colleen
like hey you've done a great job
carrying the show when we get the iron
fist back you should take it in fact she
was researching her ancestry this season
turns out her great-great-grandmother
was a pirate queen who was also maybe
the original iron fist yes the back of
her family crest is the kunlun dragon
how'd i never turn that over before so
eventually they captured davos do the
tattoo ceremony calling ops for a
tasteful sleeve instead of a full back
and now she has the white iron fist the
ceremony wasn't complete though davos
still has his so it's a big iron fist
fight now joy meacham eventually
realized even she doesn't know why she's
working for davos she tried to stay
undercover with him but when he found
out well pushed her off the balcony and
even though she was super mean to her
brother word all season he'd start to
rescue her they hired mary to now kill
davos it's like oh good mary so we're on
the same side now yeah i guess but for
some reason she and danny have a katana
fight he's gotta slash the pipe to make
the water spray out turns back into mary
but outside calling defeats davos
finishes the ritual she is now the true
iron fist then he's like yo girl i gotta
go out on an adventure to find out who i
am without the iron fist he goes to see
ward like yo man you want to go on a bro
road trip of asia with me and it's like
yeah sure i guess and so colleen's
defending the streets with her white
iron fist that lights up her whole
katana okay that's cool
and on what is apparently a bar crawl of
asia danny's now packing double pistols
and they light up with iron fist power
wow
so if this version of the character ever
comes back watch out for that now get
ready for maybe the best of the whole
bunch it is daredevil season three
at the end of the defenders it looked
like matt and elektra died in each
other's arms but matt survived did
electra make it she's never mentioned
this season so who knows
anyway this season we drop all the
mystical ninja stuff and focus back on
wilson fisk he's now ready to make a
deal with the fbi where he'll give up a
bunch of other gangs but of course we
know in prison snitches get stitches oh
he's shanked so for his own protection
the fbi has to move him to house arrest
but he's still a prisoner but eventually
he's allowed certain creature comforts
yeah he's wearing his white suits again
but he's still a prisoner except in his
closet he has a secret man cave where
he's doing crime boss stuff
yes he was playing the fbi this whole
time matt knows fisk is up to no good
and goes to the prison to investigate
but there he gets a call from fisk who
hates lawyer matt murdock for putting
him away but he didn't know that matt
murdock was also his other archnemesis
daredevil
who really shines in epic one take
hallway fights
so matt teams up with now superstar
reporter karen page to track down the
guy that fisk paid to shank him but fisk
has taken special interest in one of the
agents on his detail ben poindexter
turns out he has super
throwing skills and is a bit of a
psychopath he has a stalker crush on
this waitress so fisk sets it up that
they meet and hit it off but then kills
her and dumps him over text and this
sends him off the deep end and right
into fisk's arms so that night someone
attacks the bulletin it's dex
in the daredevil suit matt's there to
fight him he's the better boxer but
dex's throwing skills he can turn
anything in this office into a deadly
weapon he beats matt and kills the
informant eventually agent ray nadim
realizes fisk has been playing them and
tries to tell his bosses but it's like
yeah bro you're the last to know fist
controls all of us through bribes
blackmails or threats and congrats
now you work for fisk 2 or he'll kill
your family and so now with the full
power of the federal government on his
side
wilson fisk is the kingpin of new york
and now he's finally able to reunite
with his love vanessa but she doesn't
like that he's hiding his business from
her it's like yo man i mean it's super
obvious you're a crime boss i'm down
with it in fact it's her who gives the
order to kill agent nadim
at some point karen page goes to see
fisk and reveals her secret that it was
her personally who killed his best
friend wesley in season one this makes
him real mad so he sends his fake
daredevil assassin after her so matt
shows up for daredevil fight round two
this one in the church but eventually
matt finds out and tells dex that fisk
killed the girl he was stalking this
sends decks even more off the deep end
so he crashes fisk's wedding to throw
things at him and it turns into an epic
three-way brawl
in the end fist grabs decks oh breaks
his back he's out of the fight and in
the final showdown matt's beating fisk
but he knows the only way to stop him
for good is to kill him but oh the
catholic guilty just can't do it he does
though have evidence it was vanessa who
ordered the death of nadeem and so they
make a deal as long as fisk stays in
prison he won't reveal it vanessa
will be free and so wilson fisk once
again going off to jail
daredevil protecting the city and that's
how daredevil season 3 comes to an end
up next is the punisher season 2. frank
castle's quest to avenge his family is
finally all the way over he can just
relax
except one night he sees this teenage
girl chased by bad guys he can't help
himself he steps in to protect her she
explains how she had a little gang of
friends back in chicago that were hired
to get some blackmail on some politician
but apparently they blackmailed the
wrong politician because all her friends
turned up dead and now she's on the run
yes the politician's father is a
big-time ceo who has on his payroll john
proctor now a quiet religious man but he
used to be some hardcore gangster and he
is
really good at killing so the punisher
has a new sidekick that teaches him you
don't have to kill every person you meet
sometimes you can leave them alive just
burn their house down
soon they're picked up though by agent
madani like hey let's get to the main
plot because billy russo has just
escaped from the hospital yes after
frank cut up his face he wears this
crazy jigsaw mask and apparently he does
have real amnesia he doesn't remember
like being a bad guy his hot
psychiatrist feels bad for him because
he's got a wounded baby bird thing going
on and by the way his facial scars
really aren't that bad he's still hot
and these two get it on
so billy befriends a bunch of
disenfranchised vets and starts a cool
joker-style gang but soon the punisher
is here to stop him and poor billy's
mind is blown he doesn't know why his
best friend frank is trying to kill him
so he lashes out tries to kill him too
in fact madani found out billy
psychiatrist was hiding him and they
have a fight where she pushes her out
the window which was randomly her one
big fear then billy comes home they have
a fight and oh they kill each other
except actually madani survived she's
fine and billy survived too he calls up
his best friend frank like hey man i'm
so sorry what happened between us did i
betray you or something but frank has no
mercy for amnesia and this time kills
billy for good this whole time meanwhile
jon proctor's been after frank and the
girl they have a final fight in the
junkyard but turns out john proctor's
only working for the guy because he has
his sons so john proctor steps down and
lets frank get in there it's like hey
man my new sidekicks told me i don't
have to kill everyone i'm gonna let you
kill yourself yes these two became best
friends mando and baby yoda style but
now she takes a bus off to start a new
life and the punisher keeps doing what
he does best shooting up bad guys and
that brings us to the final season
jessica jones season three now the
sketchy experiment to give trish
superpowers seemed like a failure but at
the end of season two she managed to
catch her dropped phone with her foot
which
is pretty super yes the experiment
worked trish got powers well a little
bit anyway basically she's pretty good
at parkour but that's enough she's now
got what she always wanted she's a
superhero
left goes on for jess meanwhile at a bar
one night she meets a guy who promises
to make her the best burger in new york
but there's knock at the door and when
she answers oh she's stabbed what but
turns out the stabber was after burger
boy see he has a superpower too he can
sense the badness on people gives him a
horrible headache he uses it to
blackmail them he doesn't know what they
did but he says i know what you did and
they normally pay they figure the
stabber is the most recent guy who
didn't pay and turns out he's a super
genius named gregory salinger
and sure looks like he's a serial killer
he comes home right then but when just
goes to confront him he pulls a soccer
player fake injury ow you're hurting me
yeah he's got the whole thing on camera
he calls 9-1-1 on jess for breaking and
entering and assaulting him jess and
trish never made up by the way trish is
being kind of a dick but they team up
now to take down salinger they trail him
to the train car where yeah he stashed a
bunch of bodies
unfortunately there's no physical
evidence there linking him to it it's
just jessica's word and he's turning it
around on her like yo this woman's
harassing me defending him naturally is
lawyer jerry hogarth this season spends
a lot of time on her subplot of trying
to bang her college girlfriend who's a
cellist and as usual it all ends up very
poorly working for her is malcolm who's
become a really good investigator with
jessica's training working for hogarth
pays great but he's mostly helping
terrible people escape justice which he
doesn't like and now representing a
literal serial killer that's too much
for him he quits and goes back to
freelancing for jessica now eventually
the girls go on a wild goose chase to
save salinger's next victim but turns
out his relaxed target was jessica's
adopted mother
trish's real mom dorothy walker the
girls had a bad relationship with her
she wasn't overbearing showbiz mom but
love trish in her own way and natchez
finds out what it feels like to have
someone kill your mom even if they were
kind of a bad person so trish goes to
kill salinger claws his face giving her
the name hellcat just because they're in
time to stop her though like yo
killing's bad now trish can't get animal
he's in police custody but she wants to
take down some bad guys and burgerboy's
like yo i got a whole list for you they
find a killer cop gonna make him confess
but oh trish kicks him too hard she
accidentally kills him but as he dies
burgerboy's headache is lifted
confirmation for trish that she's made
the world a better place so when they go
to the next bad guy trish doesn't hold
back she kills him on purpose this time
she's like hey your head is gone right i
made the world a better place he's like
yeah but now i'm getting a headache from
you
in the end jess has to protect salinger
from trish ties her up so she could cool
off but while she's making a plan to
catch salinger whoa he poisoned her
whiskey oh now he's got jessica jones in
his power
she gets under his skin he starts
confessing all the people he's killed
and it's like hey man you fell for your
own trick you're on camera and i'm not
really poisoned so gregory salinger
going away for good the day is saved but
that's not enough for trish he busts in
there beats up these cops
and murders him in police custody yes
trish is too far gone now she thinks
she's doing the right thing and she goes
to all stab jess but blocked
and just knocks her out for the count
and now trish finally realizes maybe she
went a bit too far so jessica's best
friend trish going off to super jail
jess is gonna leave town and run away
from her problems but the lights go
purple oh that's kilgrave's voice
taunting her and she's like nah you
don't control me anymore i'm not gonna
run for my problems i'm gonna stay right
here and face them so that's where
jessica jones season three and the whole
marvel netflix defender verse comes to
an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member